«Als ich zuhause erzählte, dass ich mich in
einen Argentinier verliebt hatte, ...
... waren meine Eltern sehr offen, und
meine Mutter freute sich sehr.
Sie fand, sie erlebe mich sehr
glücklich und entspannt.
Ja, sie freuten sich sehr!»
«Wir waren in Buenos Aires an einem Tangoabend.
Ich war Assistent in einer Tangoklasse.»
«Ich war schon am Tanzen, und er kam etwas zu spät.
Ich sah ihn hereinkommen und dachte: Wow!
Dann wurde ich schon nervös.
Er band sich seine Schuhe, und ich dachte: Nein!
Er ist viel zu jung für mich! Und so ernst!
Und dann tanzten wir zusammen, und
das fühlte sich sehr gut an.»
«Normalerweise wechselt man nach einem Stück den Partner.
Der Lehrer sagte also "Partnerwechsel!"
Und wir blieben zusammen. Ich wollte eigentlich nicht wechseln.
Ich sagte: "Wir müssen nicht wechseln.
Wir tanzen!"
Dann fragte ich sie nochmals: Willst Du
Partner wechseln oder nicht?!"
Und sie sagte: "Lass uns tanzen!"»
«Er kam zwei mal in die Schweiz.
Zuerst für drei Monate, dann für sechs Monate ...
... und es hat ihm gut gefallen.
Also sagten wir, er kommt nun definitiv.
Aber so richtig besprochen und geplant ...
... Hmmm ...»
«Das haben wir nicht. Es war eher etwas spontan!
Wir wollten einfach zusammen sein!»
«Es war verrückt für mich! Aber in einem guten Sinn.
Ich musste natürlich alles lernen.
Die Leute kennenlernen, verstehen lernen,
wie es hier funktioniert ...
... und auch ihre Familie kennenlernen.»
«Ich konnte nicht als Autolackierer arbeiten, weil ...
... man braucht ...
Ich hätte eine Ausbildung haben müssen ...
... und ich hatte nur Erfahrung.»
«Einen Abschluss brauchst du hier.
Dann suchte er aber gleichzeitig Tangoschüler ...
... und vor zwei Jahren wurde dann
die Tangoschule Rafal Herbas geboren.»
«Auf sein Herz hören! Und probieren!
Nicht zuviel auf andere Leute oder Umstände schauen.
Einfach in sich hineinhorchen!»
«Das Leben ist nur einmal!
Es ist jetzt!
Wir Südamerikaner denken: Heute! Jetzt!
Ja, ich würde es weiterempfehlen!»